[موسيقى]
انه صراع يثير الاهتمام قبل فتره اعلنت
قوه فاجنر سيطرتها على بخموت وقبلها كانت
اوكرانيا قد اعلنت استعاده جزء كبير منه
وقبل ذلك بشهور كنا ننتظر وان تحكم قوات
الاتحاد الروسي سيطرتها تماما عليها لكن
وقتها توغل الاوكرانيون ضد ما نصحتهم به
قياده حلف شمال الاطلس والكنتاجون وعموما
ايا كان الوضع هناك فانه من الصعب الجزم
بانهم تخلوا عن المدينه بصفه نهائيه هم
يناورون في القتال وحتى لو كلفهم ذلك
الكثير ويترجم تقدمهما السابق مع ان يصمود
والبطوله وحتى الان يكلف ذلك الكثير من
حياه الناس من الجانبين لكن الاوكرانيين
حقيقه لم يظهروا اي نوعا من التراجع وهو
ما يمكن ان يكون الرساله التي يبعثون بها
قبل الهجوم الموعود والذي بدا في اعتقد
فيما يتعلق بخاركيب كنت في خاركيف في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير العام الماضي
عندما بدا القصف
كما تعلمون موقع مميز جدا مع محاذاتها
المباشره للحدود الروسيه كما انها ثاني
اهم مدن اوكرانيا وهي مقر لشركات كبيره في
ميدان البيكتاك ولجامعات كبرى تضم الكثير
من الشباب اليافعيين والصناعات عديده لقد
كان الاوكرانيون نشيطين جدا جدا في الذود
عنها ومع انها وقتها لم يلجا الاوكرانيون
الى الكثير من القتال والبعض قال انهم
كانوا يناورون فيما قال اخرون انهم
تراجعوا فانني اعتقد ان التعامل القوات
الروسيه معها على مستوى استراتيجي كان على
اساس انها لم تكن ضروريه في تلك الفتره
مثل ما هي عليه الان
[موسيقى]